The Last Samurai is directed by Edward
Zwick and stars Tom Cruise and Ken
Watanabe and is the story of a soldier
who is captured by the samurai and
during his captivity begins to see the
beauty in this culture and actually
chooses to side with them so why am i
reviewing the Last Samurai well this
weekend Jack Reacher never go back comes
out which is directed by edward zwick
and stars Tom Cruise as well this was
their first collaboration and it's one
of my all-time favorite films and I've
wanted an excuse to talk about this
movie for a really long time and this is
the best time to do it because they have
another collaboration coming out so
let's talk about the Last Samurai the
first time I saw this movie I was deeply
affected by it the thing that surprised
me the most and the thing that surprises
me still today is that while the battle
scenes are gloriously epic extremely
well found and very well choreographed
and everything looks brutal II realistic
the battle sequences were not the focus
of this film the focus of this film is a
heartfelt friendship that blossoms
between these two men who both come from
very different cultures Tom Cruise plays
Nathan Algren an American soldier who's
a complete drunkard he has a history of
supposed victorious war battles and he's
very decorated but he's become a drunk
idiot and after being hired to
specifically train soldiers to go out
and defeat the samurai he is eventually
captured by these very samurai he's
supposed to kill and that's when he
meets katsu moto played by Ken Watanabe
the leader of this group of samurai who
refuses to kill him he actually nurses
Ogron back to health and tries to show
him a different way of life and the fact
that this movie so wonderfully focused
on such a beautiful story between two
cultures who were clashing at the time
who learned to work together despite
their differences and who learned to
love one another that to me was very
emotionally resonant because usually
movies like this or like when can we get
to the battle sequences let's see some
decapitation some impalements let's roll
some heads come on and as I said when
the battle sequences come they are
extremely impressive and hold up very
well 13 years later there's an amazing
lack of CGI so much of it was
on in camera and still today looks
visually enthralling but I find this
film very timeless because as I said it
chooses to focus on this wonderful
friendship that grows between these
characters I am just as excited for
every scene that happens when these two
guys just sit down and have a
conversation
in fact that's something that they talk
about quite often that they just love
having conversations with each other
they love learning about each other it's
such a beautiful film in that regard
something else I want to touch on is
that when this movie came out a lot of
people were complaining that it was
another movie with a white lead that's
supposed to be about a Japanese culture
and it's called The Last Samurai and Tom
Cruise is the big epic Last Samurai hero
and these were complaints clearly made
by people who had never seen this film
because this film is about two cultures
that were at war with one another who
learned to work together and respect
each other and actually became great
friends and grew to love each other
there's nothing racist about this movie
also the title The Last Samurai the word
samurai here is plural it's about the
last remaining group of samurai this is
not singular this is not Tom Cruise this
is about the last remaining group of
this samurai culture so I find those
complaints completely ludicrous and
incredibly unwarranted also not to be
overlooked is Hans Zimmer's beautiful
score particularly the song Ronin which
was used in like every movie trailer
after news movie came out this was also
the very first time that I had ever seen
Ken Watanabe in a film and I remember
seeing it back in o3 or oh for going
holy shit who is this man this guy is
fantastic and he really is so so good in
this movie I love him in this film
because he has such a love for his
country for his culture for his Emperor
but he sees it going in a direction that
he doesn't agree with and because of his
intense love for his culture and for his
people and for his country he feels that
he has to go against this and it makes
him such a conflicted and interesting
character and that contrasts with Tom
Cruise who is also feeling very similar
conflict because he comes from a very
American
background and now we suddenly thrust
into this world in which he's seeing
people live together in peace but who
would die for each other in a moment's
instant if they had to and so these two
characters learning to work with one
another to me is fascinating to watch
and the battle sequences are amazing can
I say it again they're so good this
movie also introduced me to Hiroyuki
Sanada I tried who is one of my favorite
Japanese actors who was in the Japanese
version of ring as well as the Wolverine
I love this guy and this was the first
time I ever saw him and movie 2 and he
is so captivating he plays the guy who's
in this village that Algren is in and
he's just like I don't know about this
guy
I really don't know about you I don't
like you you're not like me and watching
those two characters learn to work
together was also really fun the last
samurai to me is a very underrated film
a lot of people like it but critics
thought it was kind of fine when it
first came out I think it's a
masterpiece I'm gonna give The Last
Samurai and A+ guys look forward to my
review of one more Tom Cruise film
before Jack Reacher never go back comes
out because I just thought I'd do a
couple Tom Cruise films leading up to
that film unfortunately it's gonna get
crammed into one very busy week because
I took a vacation as you guys know
probably so I want to review one more of
his films and it just might be directed
by mr. Steven Spielberg you guys are the
best thank you so much as always for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
[Applause]
you
[Music]